now on to some lighter news a few months
back we ran a clip of a superintendent
at the Air Force Academy chastising
racist cadets his speech came after
slurs were found on a dorm room message
board belonging to black students if you
demean someone in any way then you need
to get out and if you can't treat
someone from another race or a different
color skin with dignity and respect then
you need to get out the power of that
diversity comes together and makes us
that much more powerful we're like many
in the media we ran this clip because it
provided a power powerful response to
racism that the media demanded after
Charlotte's fell while the clip ran I
kept shaking my head for I'd seen this
story before the list of hate crime
hoaxes is long now we must add this one
to the tally according to the air force
times a black cadet admitted to writing
the slurs and he since left the school
so what's the response when we see
stories like these exposed as hoaxes
it's never as huge as the initial
response was when we assumed that it was
real which only encourages more hoaxes
for the outrage over the crime is the
only part the press seems to remember
not it's debunking which encourages the
copycats which is why we're doing this
now so people don't keep thinking this
kind of thing pays off of course social
justice warriors will repeat the
pathetic excuse that while this racist
act may be they may not be true here you
just know it's true somewhere else which
guarantees further opportunity for
attention and likely another students
expulsion I know it's crazy but maybe
it's time we stop feeding the stories to
the public before they're properly
investigated
Who am I kidding all right I think you
owe me a steak dinner because I remember
after we did this I said to you this
isn't real you did say yes dinner bets
on eight crimes yes because we're so
compassionate yes but I said after think
I might head to shake your head
have this thing where it's like I'm
going this is not G this is that true
then afterwards they go what state
dinner
I'm betting going nuts I think we'll
give you fish so what do you when you
see this if this obviously puts race
relations back because it makes
everybody suspicious of accusations now
right sure but you know I think the
reason that you're doing this is though
you think that this means that all
allegations are somehow fraud I don't
you know I'm saying I told you so why no
in this case you told me so and there
are other cases because as you were
speaking as you were doing the monologue
I think the viewers could see yeah there
is a list of people but my feeling about
this is look if you ever look at my or
at the Twitter account for this show
while I'm on you'll know that there's
some pretty harsh though are from
kilmeade killed me it's got a lot of
dummy accounts person he gets up so
early and then he just goes on after
what Kimberly is there some kind of
punishment for that like is the
punishment so man a lot of times when
people do these fake hoaxes if they say
they're under psychological stress they
need therapy
should there be stiffer penalties for
this I mean you would think so right
because when you see kind of the
cumulative effect and is a collateral
damage that results from things like
this it's really bad remember hands up
don't shoot it really put on stimulates
in a very negative way you know racial
divide and injustice and crimes that are
committed against individuals personal
and property damage I'm really hurting
communities and it's so far along after
sometimes when you find out that this
wasn't true that if you didn't sort of
search for it to follow up on it you
wouldn't know and that's why I think you
do a great job on this one thing that
you actually bring it up and you follow
up and you track it down and fake member
this when I was like hey this wasn't
true yeah I knew it was gonna happen
there was another hate crime that was
exposed as a hoax it was a Dana Kansas
State student wrote slurs on his car and
he turned out it was the victim black a
black male who would written
and so but would you here the school I
don't know I didn't mean when it comes
to this person from the Air Force
Academy yeah he's gone the punishment is
that he just missed out on a wonderful
educational opportunity yeah and so this
is a second chance no you don't think so
I'm not but I also think that this
should not take away from what I think
was a pretty amazing display of
leadership on behalf of Jay silver so
Varia with the Lieutenant General who
addresses the students immediately takes
immediate action with a pretty powerful
speech I don't know why are you gonna
take away from that yes why I don't know
I just want him because I knew it was
fake and I know it I didn't know it was
fake and he felt like he had to do
something was he trying to cut was he
trying to make cover is are you
questioning the lieutenant general I can
quit I questioned everything I
questioned you right now I don't even
know who you are anymore
Jessie thoughts thoughts yeah well I
think Kimberly's favorite poet
Shakespeare said a lie travels halfway
around the world before the truth puts
its shoes on I don't think 6% was Jim
Fixx
okay either way this is what happens and
this guy researching this is there's
hundreds of these per year we just had
one in New York where a Muslim woman
said yeah what guys in the subway
attacked me and tried to rip off my
hijab she had ended up filing a fake
police report now the motivation for
this is because people are struggling
with personal problems and they want to
feel as the victim important and they
want the attention that the victim and
victimhood guess and the victimology
industry is an incubator for these fake
hate crimes and they're mostly on
college campuses where you have these
safe spaces the microaggressions and
everybody hates a straight white male so
when these people get to college their
antennas go up and they're always
looking for sexism and homophobia and
racism and then when nothing happens
they're forced to make them up mm-hmm
instead of being a victim be a victor oh
there's a t-shirt for yeah hello shake
spirits that was Shakespeare